let's talk about the future what kind of
stuff
you you mentioned about the importance
of the biosphere
but what are the crises that are ahead
of us
that
that a chaotic dynamics view
allows us to predict it but really i saw
coming out of it
leaving aside the ecological
wasn't a crisis it was stagnation
because what we got out of the crisis
was caused by a rising level of private
debt
okay now you reach a peak level where
the willingness to take on debt
collapses
and so you go to a period where debt is
rising all the time so credit which is
the annual change in debt
and that's credit is part of aggregate
demand and aggregate income so credit
goes from positive to negative and that
causes a slump so what uh so can you
describe why that causes this lump
credit goes to negative if you ask paul
krugman he'll tell you credible is no
role in aggregate demand
okay give me a second uh credit plays no
role in an aggregate demand
so the vision the vision that the
neoclassicals have for the banking
system is what they call learnable funds
it's parkour krugman by the way the uh
the knight
at the front of the army that is the
neoclassical economist
yeah fundamentally sure okay um
uh he he's he's politically reasonable
which makes him
more dangerous than those that aren't
he's politically yeah there's quite a
lot of people that would disagree with
that characterization of paul krugman as
he's politically reasonable you should
see the people
okay okay fair enough okay
that's not a negative or positive
statement that's just he can be feisty
as well well he can he can but he's like
the human face of neoclassical economics
he doesn't deserve having a human face
it's a anti-human theory but you really
i got you all right well so
yeah uh so but the credit does not have
any effect on aggregate demand in their
model and you're saying that's not the
case it's absolutely crucial to
aggregate demand so what they model is
again the example of you lending to me
or vice versa if i lend money to you i
can spend less you can spend more okay
so
credit credit is the change in debt so
if there's if i lend money to you then
there's a level of private debt rises
okay so there's an increase in credit
but that increase in credit comes at an
expense of my spending power so you can
spend what i've lent you but i can't
spend what i've lent you so credit
cancels out but when you look at that's
learnable funds but in the real world
and the bank of england has said this is
the real world and the textbooks are
wrong categorically in
2014
when the bank lends it adds to its asset
side and says you owe us more money and
it adds to its liability site and says
here's the money in your bank account
now you spend that money so what happens
when you do your sums credit is part of
aggregate demand and aggregate income
and that's something i first solved in
2019 i think
2000 so i only recently proved it
mathematically so what that means is
credit
can is a component of aggregate demand
and credit is also very volatile it's
like consumption demand never goes
negative
investment demand never goes negative
but credit can go from positive to
negative and when you take a look at the
long run of american history after the
second world war
there was no period uh until 2007
where credit was negative it was a
positive component of gdp a positive
number
therefore when you do it as a percentage
of gdp it was a positive percentage of
gdp it peaked at 16
of gdp in 2006 2007 it fell to minus 5
in 2008 2009 so you had a 20 percent of
gdp
turn around in aggregate demand
now when you plot that against
unemployment the correlation of
credit
to unemployment
across the period from about 1990 to
2010
is about minus point nine
okay
enormous negative correlation now
according to the neoclassicals it should
be close to zero okay empirically it's
bleedingly obvious it's not and it
applies to every country in the world
that had a financial crisis at that
period so
it's it's bleedingly obvious in the data
and they ignore it because credit's not
part of their model
and you're saying it's causation that's
what it's like it's causal
today we said there's extremely high
inflation
what uh
does inflation
what role does inflation play in this
picture is a little bit of inflation
good we talked about money creation
um at the beginning
what's a little bit of inflation good or
bad a lot of inflation good or bad how
concerned very healthy
a little bit is good for a simple reason
that like again it's taken me a while to
get my head around around this but if
you think about how people say what are
the functions of money they say money
it's a unit of count account yeah you're
measuring it's a means of exchange okay
and it's a store of value okay now
yes okay it has those three roles but
the last one is contradictory of the
previous two
because and this is where you see this
with the bitcoin phenomenon
if you want to hang onto money as a
store of value
then
if prices are falling
the value of money is rising
and it's actually in your interests as a
store of value to hang on to it and not
spend it okay
so that contradicts its role as a means
of exchange
now if you have money which depreciates
and this was actually tried in this in
the austrian town of wargle during the
second before during the great
depression
if you have money that depreciates then
if you don't use it you lose it
fundamentally so it has a high rate of
circulation so there's a
a monetary theorist called silvio
gazelle
and he wrote this proposal that money
should depreciate
and he was
ridiculed and opposed and derided but
cain said he was a great intellect
and the mayor of town of wargle
in austria during the great depression
was facing an unemployment rate you know
25 percent pretty much germany had the
worst experience in the great depression
in the world but it was as bad as
america slightly worse than america
and so he thought how can i stimulate
demand here so he produced a script
which could only be used for buying
goods and services in wargle
and
uh and could be used to pay your local
rates but it was depreciated by putting
a stamp on the money if you didn't use
it so what happened was people would pay
their rates they needed to pay the rates
using this money so the script so they
use the script and it because it
depreciated you'd use it rapidly so
people were using that money this was
built alternative to the austrian
shilling and the economic activity in
town took off and unemployment fell to
zero and it was an absolute miracle and
if you loved a wargle experiment and the
austrian central bank sued them
for establishing an alternative form of
money and shut it down
unemployment went back up to 25 again
and austria voted you know what 99 point
was it 99.6
for the nazis
something crazy number like that one
when hitler marched in so the wargle
experiment showed that a depreciating
currency led to a high rate of
circulation but of course we're not
talking by my republic levels of
inflation so when you get that much
inflation and that's normally caused by
as the as the as the weimar inflation
was caused by the reparation terms
imposed on germany
fundamentally by france at the 3d
versailles
they
paid a large part of that with just
basically printing the notes and you
went into this crazy period of
hyperinflation so hyperinflation almost
always occurs when there's a massive
destruction of physical resources and
the monetary authority tries to paper
literally over it and then you get
hyperinflation that's total social
breakdown
so a moderate level of inflation
inspires the
means of exchange usage of money that
undermines the store of value usage of
money
and
and that dilemma is why we have this
antagonistic attitude towards inflation
yeah i mean you're describing his
attention
but
it's nevertheless is like money is a
store of value and a means of exchange
and i don't
you know
to push back it's not necessarily that
there's attention it's just that
depending on the dynamics of this uh
beautiful beautiful economic system of
ours it's used as one more than the
other if there's inflation you're using
it more
for the
uh means of exchange
it's deflation using more for store
value but that doesn't i don't see it as
a tension that's just a
how much you use it for those different
like but it ends up saying that overall
the level of effective commerce a bit of
inflation is a good thing because that's
depreciating the money slightly and
encourage its use yeah but so the
argument that
uh some bitcoin folks use or gold
standards
again huddle's not an argument
uh is that
having an inflation of zero
is actually achieving that balance
yeah right so like that yeah but they're
actually in favor of negative or they
they wanted to appreciate rapidly and
there's addictively negative inflation
that the
value of the value of the money rising
relative to commodities that's what they
want that's the huddle philosophy
well that's more of like an investment i
don't know if that yeah but that's more
of an investment philosophy than the
fundamental principles of why they
believe in
cryptocurrency and
enforce scarcity it's a model the the
concern there is that when you print
money
the public
policy is detached from the actual
um
from value
yeah well you get i mean this is this is
where again it matters to get money
creation right
because the government's not the only
money creator banks are as well private
banks
and
and
if we obsess too much about limiting
government money creation
what we end up getting if there is money
creation going on the private banks
doing it and you get an increase in
private debt and fundamentally private
debt and its collapse
uh
types of credit when it stops growing
that's the fundamental cause of
financial crises
so yeah but the question is what's the
the cause of the the collapse of the
uh well i think this is like the
austrian thinking leaves out the debt
deflation and that's like i think one of
the most important papers ever written
was by irving fisher called the debt
deflation theory of great depressions
fisher was somebody who
accepted the neoclassical vision he
wrote the
pre-efficiency market hypothesis
efficiency market hypothesis he had a
his his own phd called the theory of
interest
and in that he argued effectively for a
supply and demand analysis of the of the
financial system
and he argued for equilibrium
he said when you're working with a a
like a commodity market then the sale
and the uh
the transaction and the exchange occur
at the same point in time
when you're working with the financial
market then the exchange occurs through
time
so he's he said he assumed that debts
are repaid
all debts are repaid and he assumed that
equilibrium through time was an
essential part of his assumption this is
now then the great depression comes
along
and he
has become a major shareholder in the
rank xerox
because he invented the rolodex
he's a tinkerer and so he had taken out
shares
on margin and he was worth about 100
million in modern terms
when the great depression hit and 90 of
that was share market valuation he'd
taken out margin debt just like
everybody else
and with margin debt you could put down
a hundred thousand dollars and buy a
million dollars worth of shares
so you got this huge leverage into debt
now that when the financial crisis hit
the level of margin debt in america had
risen from half a percent of gdp in 1920
to 13 of gdp
in 1929 it then fell to zero again
that's why the stock market crash in 29
was so devastating that scale of of
margin lending
and everyone was being wiped out they
were selling rolls-royces for 20 quid
you know that you literally have
photographs showing people doing that
because a margin call comes in you've
got to liquidate everything
okay so you said the danger is is of a
debt deflation is what we have to avoid
okay and that means
you don't want too much private debt to
accumulate
and you don't want
falling prices because the falling
prices will amplify
the impact of being insolvent to begin
with
and that's what we saw in the great
depression it's partially what we saw in
2007 but we didn't have anything like
the level of of margin debt margin debt
was reduced from 90 to 50 ratio after
the great depression um so there were
limits on how bad it was in 2007
but
the danger is still the period of
deflation amplifies your debts
okay and he's he i call it fisher's
paradox he didn't write those terms
himself but he wrote a line saying the
more debtors pay the more they owe
okay and this is because you're
liquidating to try to
meet your own debts
when you liquidate the price level falls
you will end up having a lower level of
monetary debt but a higher level of debt
when you deflate it using the price
level so the biggest danger in
capitalism is the debt deflation
far more dangerous than inflation and
the cause of debt deflation is
too much lending too much bank lending
too much private money creation
and if you take a look at the 1920s
calvin coolidge
explained the boom of the 1920s on his
surplus he said my government running a
surplus of one percent of gdp pretty
much from 1922 through to 1930 is the
foundation of our stability it should be
continued what he didn't look at was
that over that same time period
on average americans were borrowing five
percent of gdp per year from the private
banks
so you had a housing bubble at the
beginning of the 1920s which richard
vague covers beautifully in the uh a
brief history of doom
and then you had this huge rise in
margin debt as well gigantic increase in
margin debt
so all this borrowed money was being
spent into the economy and this is where
credit becomes part of aggregate demand
and it's both not just for goods and
services it's also for shares and houses
and so on so a huge valuation effect
but then when the margin debt turned
around when people would not take out
margin debt anymore the demand for
margin debt disappeared and then it was
a you know what we call badly a positive
feedback loop is actually an amplifying
feedback loop and that caused a collapse
so
what elements of that do you see today
that we need to fix and how do we fix it
we have to regard the level of private
debt as a target of economic policy just
as much as the rate of inflation or the
rate of unemployment how do wha what is
the moderate amount of private debt
that's good i would say something of you
anywhere between 30 and 70 of gdp
what is it currently uh in america it's
a hundred and seventy percent
nice
of gdp of gdp oh that's nice i've got
the people
after we talk but i can show you the
data in this and it's
it it is just this huge increase in
private debt yeah the cause first of all
caused the boom
but then financing the credit causes
ultimately causes the slump and so if we
remove the
rate level at which debt can reach and
we stop speculative lending and base
have a lending for both uh innovation
invest investment and
essential consumption items we won't
have the slump on the other side we can
we can get rid of financial instability
we can't stop financial cycles
but we can stop financial breakdown
you